[Música]
gracias por acompañarme una semana más
en medioambiente de france 24 comenzamos
en francia donde el estado fue declarado
culpable de inacción climática en un
fallo que aunque simbólico por ahora
varias organizaciones ambientales han
calificado de histórico nuestra
periodista en parís
erika olavarría con el contexto y todos
los detalles de la decisión de la
justicia francesa el proceso del siglo
fue iniciado hace dos años por cuatro
ong medioambientales francesas a imagen
de una fundación de los países bajos que
en el año 2018 logró condenar al estado
de ese país por no hacer lo suficiente
para luchar en contra del calentamiento
global estas ongs francesas consideran
lo mismo que el estado francés no ha
hecho lo suficiente para luchar en
contra del cambio climático y que por
ejemplo a la velocidad que está yendo no
va a conseguir de aquí al año 2050 esa
neutralidad de carbono a la que se
comprometió los acuerdos del clima de
parís se basan para decir esto en muchos
informes entre ellos el informe anual
del alto consejo para el clima de
francia publicado a fines del año pasado
que decía que justamente la velocidad
que está llevando francia en la lucha
contra el cambio climático no es la de
y entonces en un tiempo récord en menos
de un mes consiguieron más de 2 millones
de firmas y presentaron su denuncia
frente a un tribunal administrativo el
14 enero fue la primera audiencia y hace
poco conocimos al veredicto este juzgado
consideró que el estado francés es
responsable de inacción climática lo
obliga a pagar un euro simbólico a estas
organizaciones pero lo que es más
importante le pide a las ongs que
entreguen una lista de medidas que
consideran que debe tomar el estado para
reparar el daño climático y por qué es
importante este veredicto porque
considera que el estado es responsable
del cambio climático de los daños que
produce y lo obliga a reparar esos
perjuicios eso abre la vía por ejemplo a
que una persona que se siente afectada
por el calentamiento global se querellen
contra el estado francés pero también es
muy importante esta decisión judicial
porque llega a pocos días de que el
presidente y su gobierno presenten su
proyecto de ley clima que es aquel que
recoge las sugerencias de la convención
ciudadana el clima
un grupo de 150 ciudadanos franceses de
todos los colores políticos y de todas
las clases sociales sugerencias para
luchar en contra del cambio climático
entre ellas por ejemplo inscribir el
cuidado del medio ambiente
en la constitución francesa
en dos meses estas sugerencias de acción
contra el cambio climático que tienen
que escribir las ongs llegarán ante los
tribunales y ahí la justicia podrá
decidir qué medidas concretas tendrá que
tomar el gobierno de francia por su
parte el portavoz del elíseo admitió que
el país está atrasado en la lucha contra
el cambio climático aunque también hizo
un llamado para que los que recriminan
la inacción gubernamental propongan
soluciones para incrementar el impacto
positivo y es más que razonable decir
que nuestro país ha acumulado un retraso
desde hace años en la lucha contra el
calentamiento global
comparto esta lógica y es una de las
razones por las que me comprometí junto
a emanuel macrón a ejercer una acción
ambiental de defensa del medio ambiente
extremadamente ambiciosa como las que
tenemos desde 2017 y que están
reforzadas más que nunca con el plan de
30 mil millones de euros para la
transición ecológica así que comparto
esta visión y estamos respondiendo no
hace falta que los que le piden al
estado que vaya más allá propongan
medidas para llegar a ese objetivo de
llegar más lejos se alió con confirmó
una de las ongs que interpuso la demanda
contra
el estado asegura que sabe perfectamente
sobre qué aspectos hay que trabajar más
pero que lo importante de esta sentencia
es que pone la pelota en el terreno del
gobierno que según ellos siempre intenta
evadir su responsabilidad climática y
recordó que las acciones valen más que
las palabras
no podemos cargar a los ciudadanos con
la responsabilidad de luchar contra el
cambio climático el estado debe actuar a
través de políticas públicas ya que sin
decisiones colectivas no tendremos éxito
eso ha quedado muy claro cuáles son las
decisiones en las que podemos guiar al
estado en políticas de transporte de
aislamiento térmico sabemos cuáles son
los campos en los que hay que actuar y
para estos no sólo hay que tener
objetivos teóricos en papel o grandes
frases sino que hacen falta acciones y
medios que los respalden esta decisión
del 3 de febrero se une además a la
fecha límite que tiene el estado francés
este mismo mes para justificar que está
dando los pasos adecuados para alcanzar
sus objetivos a 2030 en la lucha contra
el cambio climático en este caso por una
demanda interpuesta en enero de 2019 por
la municipalidad costera de ica van sant
un suburbio de dunkerque al norte del
país que siente que es muy vulnerable al
aumento del nivel del mar como
consecuencia del calentamiento global
más allá de lo que suceda en francia con
estas decisiones el veredicto puede
abrir las puertas a que los ciudadanos
de otros países sean
ven a interponer demandas contra los
gobiernos para exigir por ley más
acciones para revertir o frenar el
cambio climático y precisamente una de
las maneras de reducir las emisiones de
gases que contribuyen al calentamiento
global es lo que se llama la economía
circular que básicamente consiste en
consumir menos y reciclar más para así
reducir al máximo la cantidad de nuevos
recursos utilizados según el último
reporte de la empresa de economía
circular de los 100 mil millones de
toneladas de materiales utilizados cada
año sólo el 8,6 por ciento se vuelve a
poner en circulación para su uso es
decir que el 91,4 por ciento de todos
los materiales que usamos se desechan al
finalizar su uso que a veces es de tan
solo segundos y la tendencia va en
descenso
una economía circular permitiría hacer
más con menos reduciría las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero en un 39 por
ciento y haría descender en un 28 por
ciento la cantidad de recursos vírgenes
que tendríamos que extraer o utilizar
para justamente transición hacia un
sistema económico sostenible
américa latina y el caribe lanzaron la
coalición de economía circular que
pretende unir esfuerzos entre gobiernos
empresas y sociedad civil para
desvincular el crecimiento económico de
la degradación ambiental es tiempo de
reconocer que los patrones de producción
y consumo son la causa fundamental de la
triple crisis planetaria del cambio
climático la pérdida de biodiversidad y
la contaminación aprovechamos esta
oportunidad única para repensar nuestra
economía lineal y reconfigurar esos
patrones insostenibles con un
recordatorio para que consumamos de
acuerdo a las tres erres reducir
reutilizar y reciclar me despido hasta
la próxima
[Música]